more than 40 million Americans have
already cast their votes that includes
record early turnout for midterm in
Georgia the kokilian is in Atlanta
Nicole good morning what is the picture
like there
hey
hey good morning to you Nate and with so
many critical races here voter turnout
for the midterm elections has hit an
all-time high with more than two and a
half million Georgians voting early
right now the Georgia Senate race is in
a virtual tie with polls showing no
clear leader emerging before election
day in their closing arguments
Republican Senate nominee Herschel
Walker made no mention of allegations
from two women that he paid for them to
have abortions instead his message has
focused on tying Democratic senator
Rafia Warnock to President Joe Biden
Warnock was joined on the trail this
weekend by Spike Lee the senator has
defended his record and says Walker is
not fit to serve tonight Walker and
Republican Governor Brian Campbell hold
events in the same city but it's not
clear if they'll make a joint appearance
in fact they have not campaigned
together at all in recent weeks Kemp
holds an edge in his rematch against
Stacey Abrams who is seeking to become
the first black female governor in U.S
history history If no candidate gets 50
percent of the vote tomorrow night then
a runoff election will be held in
December Gail
all right we are all watching thank you
Nicole